I think a lot of people just assume that
the way to make a eyes more intelligent
just to make them more human but I think
that's a very dubious assumption I think
we're much better off with tools and
with colleagues we can make tools that
are smarter than Dickens and use them
and understand what their limitations
are without giving them ulterior motives
purposes a drive to exist and to compete
and to beat the others those are
features that don't play any crucial
role in the competences of artificial
intelligence so for heaven's sakes
don't bother putting them in leave all
that out and what we have is very smart
thingies that we can treat like slaves
and it's quite alright to treat them as
lice because they they don't have
feelings they're not conscious you can
turn them off you can tear them apart
the same way you can with an automobile
and that's the way we should keep it now
that we're in the age of intelligent
design
lots of intelligent designers around a
lot of them are intelligent enough to
realize that Orgel second rule is true
evolution is cleverer than you are
that's Francis Crick's famous quit and
so what they're doing is harnessing
evolutionary processes to do the heavy
lifting without human help so we have
all these deep learning systems and they
come in two varieties there's Bayesian
networks and and reinforcement learning
of various sorts deep deep learning
neural networks and what these computer
systems have in common is that they are
competent without comprehension
Google Translate doesn't know what it's
talking about when it translates a bit
of Turkish into a bit of English doesn't
have to it's not as good as the
translation that a bilingual can do but
it's good enough for most purposes and
what's happening in many fields in this
new wave of AI is the creation of
systems black boxes where you know that
the probability of getting the right
answer is very high they are extremely
good they're better than human beings at
churning through the data and coming up
with the right answer but they don't
understand how they do it nobody
understands in detail how they do it and
nobody has to so we've created entities
which are is inscrutable to us as a bird
or a mammal considered as a collection
of cells as inscrutable it's still a lot
we don't understand about what makes
them tick and we can use these products
these intellectual products without
knowing quite how they're generated but
knowing having good responsible reasons
for believing that they will generate
the truth most of the time no existing
computer system no matter how good it is
at answering questions like Watson on
Jeopardy no such system is conscious
today not closed and although I think
it's possible in principle to make a
conscious Android conscious robot I
don't think it's desirable I don't think
there would be great benefits to doing
this and there will be some significant
harms and dangers too you could at
tremendous expense but you have to have
in fact quite a quite a revolution in in
computer design which would take you
right down right down to the very base
of the hardware
[Music]